[Music]
we're four days walk from the nearest
road the landscapes vast the wilderness
is almost unlimited the access is by
aircraft on foot or on the right day you
can boat it but it's a challenge in
itself
really we are at the mercy of the
weather and the tides and our day-to-day
life it's difficult living out here but
if you do what's needed and everything
comes together it's a really rewarding
place to be
[Music]
warrick Mitchell lives in fuel and New
Zealand's oldest and largest national
park it covers over 12,000 square
kilometers but is home to only a few
dozen people the parks massive Mountain
Ranch isolates Warwick from civilization
living out here like everywhere you need
shelter a good dry camp we have solar
panel for power lighting and satellite
communications we have a quad bike we
have two boats for fishing and diving
and we have the freezer which keeps our
food and our produce cold
we rely on rainwater for drinking water
so that's not too hard with seven meters
of rainfall annually we largely live off
the land when you're living off the land
you really at the mercy of the weather
and the elements so there's certain
times that will allow you to go out and
harvest a deer or catch a fish capture
the menu
[Music]
if you have a down day and the waves are
really good you're more than likely
going to go surfing if the waves aren't
good but the rivers looking nice you
might catch a trout if the waves the
flat for the oceans come you might go
see fishing if the oceans stormy you
might go up the river for a kayak or go
through the bush and see if you can spot
a deer
[Music]
living in the wilderness doesn't mean
you're living in isolation from people
we certainly couldn't be doing what we
do if it wasn't for their pilots and our
neighbors and our friends whether it's
the harshness of the environment and
being so isolated that brings people
together or the fact that the people
that are willing to travel this far have
like-minded passion for the environment
and the outdoors one thing's for sure
over the years is that the communities
become really tight-knit can you go
ahead and turn this main switch on and
we'll just see if she wants to work know
when things break or things don't go
your way it's always really important to
remember you're in the green the
experiences being out here and enjoying
being out here everything else is a
bonus so you can't get too serious if
one thing breaks I don't know too many
places in the world where you can stand
on a boat looking back and you can just
see ocean leading into forests leading
into massive snow-capped mountains in
Glacier shaped Bay's with pristine
rivers and clear water the trees are as
they were 200 years ago and the people
that I bring out here they get to
experience this nature as it was and as
it should be and we try to keep the area
and the environment pristine in this
little corner of New Zealand here we are
in the whole valley rainforest
this is a cathedral lie to the
in this forest is the quietest place in
the entire United States and it's only
one square inch of the size my mission
is to keep it that way
I'm Gordon Hempton I'm a sound tracker I
travel the globe in search of vanishing
sounds including the most endangered of
all which is simply silence noise
pollution is nearly enix capable the
whole valley is the quietest least noise
polluted place and the entire lower 48 I
don't know if I can save silence but I
know that I can try so it was 12 years
ago
2005 Earth Day that I hiked up the HOH
River Valley
it took three miles just to escape the
notice of the parking lot that's when I
was looking in every direction for which
way I should go
I saw the elk trail love to follow their
advice because they love quiet just like
I do
and they led me right to the spot I
defend this one square inch of silence
by doing both quiet and noise monitoring
when a noise intrusion occurs I locate
the noise maker send them a letter and
ask for compliance this matter is urgent
within ten years it's likely that there
will be no quiet places left unless we
take action when I first started I did
not think silence would go extinct in my
lifetime
and if that happens the quiet will
disappear and the wildlife will be
devastated the one square inch of
silence foundation is pressing our
politicians to pass a single piece of
legislation that will designate Olympic
National Park as the world's first quiet
park off-limits to aircraft all things
are possible the earth is here and it's
beautiful and for me it all starts here
in the whole valley a plank I've came up
with the largest collection of old
American cars in the world
you know all of them have the story but
they kindly take their place in the
forest you know and they're part of the
forest
they grew up partially in the forest
[Music]
my name is Walter Dean Lewis
I've run and operated on hokar City USA
I was born and raised in a junkyard and
I like junkyards
[Music]
this land was clear when I started
putting them in there
I wanted nature to take its course and
we just led to go wild
these cars come from other junkyards and
just individual people and they all wind
up here at old car city
[Music]
Ford Chevrolet Joe motors they land out
there in the forest rotting away
[Music]
we build things out of brushed out there
and it is a piece of art
[Laughter]
first came the grasses they came in
thick then smaller shrubs with them the
insects returned then the trees and with
the trees the monkeys and elephants here
at a sanctuary
we have over 300 acres a forest that we
have replanted and brought back to life
[Music]
my full name is Pamela Gayle multi-track
and I am co-founder with my husband of
size sanctuary trust it had always been
our dream to have a private forest
sanctuary for wildlife where they would
be protected when we first came here
most of the lands that were sold to us
were abandoned lands abandoned rice
field coffin and Hardiman fields as well
a lot of deforestation had taken place
and that took a lot a lot of care and
energy and time and years to bring it
back to really done well this year
people thought you were quite crazy but
that's okay a lot of people have thought
people that have done some amazing
things are crazy here in the sanctuary
it is a biodiversity hotspot I remember
walking through the forest you wouldn't
hear anything but the sound of your own
feet now
[Music]
the place is alive with sound
[Music]
one of our main sound makers are the
cicadas they have a tremendous decibel
range where they start again we keep
striving to do more and more but the
initial goal has been more than achieved
my hope for the next 10 years for this
forest is that it will continue to be
protected and expanded we both feel a
tremendous amount of joy when we walk
through the sanctuary I've never felt
this kind of joy and then anything else
that I've done in my life
[Music]